ce soldat eux craignent un patrouillent
dans les tranchées à quelques mètres
seulement des factions russe sur cette
ligne de front située entre l'ukraine et
la région de lougansk sous contrôle
séparatiste la tension est palpable
depuis des mois pour ses soldats la
question n'est plus de savoir si la
russie de vladimir poutine va vraiment
attaquer mais qu'en moyenne c'est quand
même mon
petit nathan le bon moment
d'un point de vue militaire ce n'est pas
le bon moment pour attaquer
notamment à cause des conditions
météorologiques qui sont très durs pour
les véhicules et l'infanterie
depuis fin 2021 plus de cent mille
militaires russes se sont massés à la
frontière selon les estimations des
occidentaux sur le front diplomatique
l'objectif est donc de tenter de
dissuader la russie d'envahir l'ukraine
le premier ministre britannique a
annoncé que la grande-bretagne
proposerai la semaine prochaine à ses
alliés de l'otan diverses mesures dont
un déploiement majeur de troupes en
europe
la priorité numéro un est de dissuader
vladimir poutine d'envahir l'ukraine
c'est pourquoi nous proposons de
déployer des troupes supplémentaires en
espérant vous proposons de fournir
davantage de soutien aérien aux maires
noirs et des armes défensives à
l'ukraine pour nous assurer que le pays
sera dans la meilleure position possible
en cas d'incursion de vladimir poutine
pour autant l'organisation du traité de
l'atlantique nord l'a redit l'ukraine
n'étant pas membre de l'alliance
militaire en déploiement de ses troupes
est exclu la russie s'estiment menacés
par l'élargissement de l'otan à ses
frontières et réclame de la part de
l'occident des garanties sécuritaires
dont celle de ne pas voir l'ukraine
intégrer l'alliance un point clé rejetée
par washington et ses alliés qui se
disent prêt en revanche à discuter de la
question du contrôle des as